Okay. Yeah. So, you said that you hate
our disingenuous arguments, but I would
say the opposite. Uh, you guys
definitely Well, I spoke to you. You
hate your Quran, man, cuz we we we we
went over some verses and you showed
that you reject the Quran, bro. My
goodness.
>> I spoke to you for 2 hours about your
reading comprehension. You just refuse
to understand the Quran and its
totality. You like to isolate stuff.
>> You want to see an example of you hating
the Quran?
>> Um, to be honest with you, I came up
here to talk to you about Allah having a
son. I talked to your man Darren about
it the other day. He was also
disingenuous. Oh,
>> okay. Well, that's not this topic. Well,
we could kind of it it's kind of on that
on that range. Um, when it when it comes
to Allah having a son, Darren is right
here, too. When it comes to Allah having
a son, [clears throat] could he have a
son by himself or would he need a mate
to have a son with?
>> There's nothing in the Quran that
suggests that if he chose to have a son,
a mate would be um that would be
something obligatory. So when chapter 6
vers 101 says he's the originator of the
heavens and the earth, how can he have a
son when he doesn't have a mate?
>> Right. So this is one example of why
Allah does not have a son. It's not the
only example of
>> when he says how can that's dealing with
somebody's ability. Right.
>> Correct.
>> So when he says how can he have a son
when he doesn't have a mate means that
he needs a mate in order to have a son.
Right. If that was the only verse of the
Quran, I might agree with you. But we
have other Quran verses as well that
disagree with that understanding.
>> So that means that there's other verses
to contradict this verse then.
>> No, we we call it what you Christians
call it, the harmonization between the
verses.
>> So when the Quran says, "How can he have
a son when he doesn't have a mate?" You
would agree that this statement is
communicating that he needs a mate to
have a son in this verse, right? No, I
would agree that Allah does not have a
son. And he's given one example of why
he doesn't have a son. For instance, he
doesn't have a mate.
>> Well, he doesn't say that that's why he
doesn't have a son. It's it's a how can
he how can he have a son when he doesn't
have a mate? So, it's talking about his
ability to have a son. Right.
>> Sorry, I got it.
>> It's okay.
>> So, we go over to the Quran um 39:4. It
clears things up on that.
>> What does it say? So this would be the
second premise to your argument. And it
says God could have chosen from his
creation whom he willed for offspring.
But he is far above this. He is the one
the almighty. So it says here clearly
that he could have chose.
[clears throat] It doesn't say he could
have chosen a mate. It says he could
have chose from his creation to be his
offspring.
>> Yeah. And how would he have that
offspring?
>> The verse is clear. He would have just
chosen them.
>> Well, so if if this is the case, cuz
this is this is where we're at. Either
the verses harmonize or they contradict.
One verse says that Allah needs a mate
in order to have a son. And the other
verse says that he can choose a son. So
this would mean that the only way that
he can choose a son is is if he has a
mate to be able to choose a son with. Or
else you have a contradiction.
>> So I would say no. This is your
understanding of what the verse is
saying and I don't fault you for having
that understanding. But what I'm telling
you is that when the Quran says, "How
can Allah have a son when he has no
mate?" This doesn't imply that this is
the only avenue for him to have a son
had he chose to do that.
>> When it says that, I'll ask it again
just to make it clear. When it says how
can that deals with someone's ability
that's dealing with Allah's ability,
correct?
>> If you want to word it like that. Yeah.
>> All right. So, we agree that this is
talking about Allah's ability. So in
regards to his ability to have a son, it
says how can he have a son when he
doesn't have a mate? Meaning he doesn't
have the ability to have a son without a
mate. Correct.
>> No, sir.
>> Then you [clears throat] hate
congratulations. You hate your Quran,
bro. You hate your Quran.
>> So once again, so just on the verse that
we're on, not going anywhere else. So if
Allah says, "How can he have a son when
he has no mate?" Would that be
contradictory for me saying how can
Allah have a son when uh there's nobody
uh nobody high enough to be his son?
Would those now be two contradictory
statements or would they just be
different examples of why he doesn't
have a son?
>> Those those if you were to harmonize
them, it's dependent on Allah having a
mate to even have a son to choose in the
first place. So what you're basically
saying about Islam in the Quran is that
Allah Allah has some type of um ability.
Mating ability is what you're saying.
>> That's what the Quran says, not me.
>> No, this is what I mean when I say you
guys misrepresent our text. No one in a
thousand years has ever believed that
what the Quran says is that Allah has
the ability to mate.
>> That's a big claim. I'm pretty sure that
there would be people that would ag that
that would disagree, but I I I couldn't
care less about what people think Allah
can do. I only take from the Quran and
what the Quran says Allah can do. And
according to the verse, Allah is
refuting people who are saying he has
children, has offspring by saying, "Hey
guys, how can I have a son? How can I
have offspring when I don't have a mate?
Meaning, if he had a mate, then he can
have a son. And therefore, you guys can
can bring these accusations that he has
a son. If he had a mate, but he doesn't
have a mate. So, that eliminates any
possibility that he has a son. That's
his reputation.
>> Okay. So, let's read another verse and
see if you if you keep that same energy.
>> Why do we have to go to another verse?
We didn't read we didn't finish this
one. because my argument seems to you
you seem to not be catching it or you're
catching it and ignoring it. So, we're
just going to make it plain for you and
the people.
>> If if I if I say how can I drive the car
when I don't have the keys, that means
that by by the statement that I need the
keys to drive the car. Correct?
>> That means that that's one thing you
need but not the only thing that you
need.
>> Got it. So, one thing that Allah needs
to have a son is a mate. Correct.
>> No, sir.
>> Ah,
there it is. [laughter and gasps]
Congratulations,
Abu Norori. You hate your Quran.
>> I mean, you can say all that, but you
gave a an example of someone needing
keys to drive a car, and now you're
comparing that to God having a mate.
They're two different.
>> Yeah. So, I'm I'm not comparing Allah
having a son with somebody having a car
or keys. I'm comparing the grammar of
the statement. The statement is how can
I drive the car when I do not have the
keys? Meaning I need the keys to drive
the car. That's what the that's what the
statement communicates. Same way Allah
says, how can I have a son when I do not
have a mate? Meaning I need a mate in
order to have a son. That's what the
statement itself communicates. So it's
communicating a need is what I'm saying.
Both both the statement communicates a
need.
>> So your claim is that Allah needs a mate
to have a son. Is that correct?
>> It's not my claim cuz I love the Quran.
The Quran makes the claim. Okay. I'm
only reading. What's the only thing we
doing around here, fellas?
>> We just read, man. We just read.
>> That's it.
>> Just read.
>> The little song. Just read.
>> You just read. But why you not reading
394 that I gave you that says he would
have chosen? Why you just read what you
want to read?
>> You know what? I like I told you because
I love the Quran before it got
corrupted. I love the original Quran. I
can I see a way to harmonize those
verses. I I could take the other route
out and say, "Well, those verses just
contradict each other." Cuz one is
saying that Allah can choose to have a
son if he wanted to with with no help.
The other one is saying that he does
need help to have a son. So I could go
that route and just say it's a
contradiction. However, I don't believe
that it's a necessarily a contradiction.
I believe that both are harmonized that
Allah can choose a son from his
creation. If he wanted to have a son, he
would just need a mate to do it. He need
help.
>> And does that agree with the the spirit
of the Quran and its verses?
>> That agrees with the spirit of the Quran
and its verses because the ver the Quran
is explicit that one, he needs a mate to
have a son and if there were any
contradictions in the book, it would not
be from Allah. I love the Quran, man.
I'm trying to I'm trying to defend it.
I'm on team Allah. I I love the original
Quran. So, I believe these verses
harmonize. I don't think it's a
contradiction. Allah needs to make to
have a son. Man,
>> it's in the Quran.
>> It's It's not my thoughts. It's not my
interpretation. It's what it says.
>> The Quran does not say that Allah needs
a mate to have a son. What the Quran
does say?
>> Yeah. So, what Allah does say in the
Quran is how could he have a son when he
has no m. So it doesn't mean here that
if he were to choose to have a son that
having a mate would be that that's
contingent upon him having a mate.
That's not what's meant here. That's not
how we understand it. That's the
understanding the straw man you're
choosing to argue against.
>> A straw man.
>> Straw man.
>> Tell me what a straw man is real quick.
Abonori,
>> it's you creating an argument and then
arguing against that. So creating a
false argument, creating a false
representation of a belief or position
and then arguing against that false
representation. Correct.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. Be honest with me. Be honest with
me. You you you usually, you know, kind
of balance. Sometimes you're honest with
me, sometimes I feel like you're not.
But for the most part, you're honest
with me. Did I read the Quran verse
verbatim?
>> Yeah. You read it verbatim.
>> Okay. And according to the Quran verse
verbatim, it says, "How can he have a
son when he doesn't have a mate?" That's
what it says verbatim, right?
[clears throat]
>> Yes, sir.
>> So, when it says that verbatim, what
does that entail when he says, "How can
he have a son when he doesn't have a
mate?" What does he need based on the
statement? Based on what the Quran says,
based on this statement? What does he
need in order to have a son?
>> Based on that statement alone with no
other statement? Is that what you're
trying to force me into?
>> No, just based on this statement. based
on the statement.
>> So I'm not a one verse Muslim. We accept
[clears throat] the Quran in its
totality. This
>> I understand. I'm just the statement
itself. What is what is the what does
the statement entail?
>> Sure. No problem. Let's play your game.
If I were to isolate this verse and
ignore the rest of the Quran, then it
would entail exactly what you're saying,
sir.
>> So,
>> good thing we don't have to do that.
>> So, I'm not asking you to isolate
anything. The only thing I'm asking you
to do is to tell me like like for
example, if I were to ask you um when it
says when it says um in the Quran um
Allah does not begget nor is he
begotten. What does that what does that
mean?
>> It means Allah does not have children
nor is he the child of someone.
>> There's a there's a there's some
feedback was going on there. Oh, that
was hurting.
>> Yeah, I'm moving around. My wife's sick
and I got my kids in here with his loud
music. You can probably hear.
>> Okay, you're good now though. So it it
means exactly what it says that Allah
doesn't have children, right? Nor is he
born.
>> Correct.
>> Do you need another verse to tell you
what that statement means?
>> No, I don't need another verse for that
specific statement.
>> So you're [clears throat] able to
comprehend statements,
blatant explicit statements that the
Quran makes without having to go to
other verses to tell you what a verse
just said. Right? you can look at what
the Quran says very clearly um when it's
clear on something. Now I can grant you
with if there's something that's a
little bit more ambiguous you can use or
you might need other verses to make
bring some clarity on the on the subject
but when things are just I mean
blatantly said you don't need another
verse to come and be like oh well I
can't understand when it's when Allah
says uh he doesn't begin nor is he
begotten I don't understand what that
means so let me go to another verse to
figure out what this is saying you don't
need that so in the same way this This
is a very clear and explicit statement.
How can he have a son when he does not
have a mate? The statement is clear.
Based on the statement, what would Allah
need according to the statement to have
a son?
>> Am I free to answer?
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So once again, like I've said two
or three times now, you keep on trying
to force me into this narrow hallway
where all I have is one verse to work
with. What you did a second ago was you
said some verses are clear. You don't
need an extra extra explanation from
another verse. Some verses are
ambiguous. In that case, you might. I
say that once again, you misrepresent us
because that's not the only options. For
instance, let's give a reasonable
example. Allah says in the Quran to
strike at their fingertips. Can I just
isolate that and every time I see a
Christian going on? No. Is that verse
ambiguous? No. I understand what strike
their fingertips off means. But I need
another verse to fully understand what
that means. Though it's not um
ambiguous. So the same thing applies
here. The verse is not ambiguous, but it
doesn't necessitate because it's not
ambiguous
that there's not other verses that go
into the proper understanding of. Would
[snorts] you agree that the verse about
strike them at their fingertips is in a
context with verses before and after it
that tells you what Allah is talking
about and the situation he's talking
about?
>> Yes. And in verses and other chapters,
>> right? So the verse within strike their
fing strike at their fingertips is
giving you a particular situation in
context that you see within the verses
that that same verse is in. You see that
within that. So I you don't have to go
to another verse, another chapter to
figure out what it's saying here.
Although you can, no problem. I'm not
saying that that's not allowed. But you
don't need to do that to bring clarity
for the Quran in every situation. You
don't need to do that even for that
verse you brought up. You don't got to
do that. See, notice I can give you I I
give the Quran credit where credit's
due. There's sometimes, not majority of
times it doesn't, but there's sometimes
where it actually gives context where
you read a verse and the context helps
you understand what the heck it's
talking about. So for example, when it
says in our verse chapter 6 verse 101,
its context, the prior verse before says
that they are saying they are
attributing the gins as associates with
him and saying that Allah has children,
has sons and daughters. Then the next
verse says he's the originator of the
heavens and the earth. How can he have a
son when he doesn't have a mate and he's
the creator of all things, the knower of
all things. So I don't need to go into
another verse to tell me what this
means. Allah is clearly refuting this
idea that he has children. Can you agree
with me there?
>> Yes. and he use and one of the methods
he the reasoning that he uses is that he
doesn't have a mate to have children
with. That's how he refutes this claim
that he doesn't that he has uh that he
has children. Right.
>> Yes.
>> So I don't need a beat that's super
dumping. Nor do I need another verse in
the Quran to tell me what this means. I
see it right there in its context and in
the explicit statements. So when the
very detailed explanation the Quran says
how can he have a son when he doesn't
have a mate clearly shows Allah needs a
mate in order to have a son because he
doesn't have a mate or companion that's
equal to him or worthy of being his
companion. Therefore he can't have a son
because he doesn't have anybody to mate
with. Therefore, it's refuted that he
has a son or a daughter. It's done.
Pretty clear, right?
>> Can I go ahead and go now?
>> Yeah. Do Do you believe that that's a
clear a clear understanding?
>> I believe that that one thing is indeed
clear that Allah does not have a M and
we don't have a problem with this. So,
the problem is that Allah is describing
in this verse not the totalities of
avenues in which if he will he could
take a son. Allah is um basically
clarifying that he doesn't have children
and he's getting rid of one avenue in
which that's possible.
>> Why doesn't he have children? Why
[clears throat] doesn't he have children
>> in this one avenue? Because he doesn't
have a mate.
>> So according to this verse, he would
need a mate to have children.
>> No. And I feel like now you're purposely
misrepresenting me, bro. Cuz I'm trying
to be as clear as possible.
>> He hates the Quran, man.
>> You hate the Hey, congratulations. You
hate the Quran. If you if you didn't
finish, I want you to go ahead and get
the last word, Abu Norah, because you're
very respectful. Go ahead and get the
last word. I'm going go ahead and let
somebody else up to to also showcase why
they hate the Quran, too.
>> Yeah. So, I'll just end with this is the
issue here. What you're doing is forcing
us down this one avenue. We don't we're
not forced down this one avenue by way
of the Quran. You're forcing us down
this avenue by way of your own
understanding, which is premature. I
think that I made it clear that this one
avenue of Allah taking a son, if you
will, is with the maid. But according to
the explicit statements in the Quran, it
would not be the only avenue, but Allah
gets rid of all of those avenues. And I
can leave it there. That's it.
>> All right. Appreciate you for
participating, man. Thank you. Oh, okay.
I guess he's really done. All right, Abu
Nori. I'll catch you on another one,
man. These Muslims hate the Quran, man.
>> They sure do. There has not been one
Muslim today, Avery, that has not hated
their Quran. They all hate their Quran.
Every one of them. Switch it back to
Streamyard, y'all.
>> Yeah. They hate their Quran, man.
>> Yep. They hate the Quran. Y'all see it?
Y'all see it? We The only thing we're
doing is What What's the only thing we
doing around here, fellas?
>> We just read.
>> We just reading that Quran. reading that
Muslims, having them read it,
>> and they denying it, rejecting it,
twisting it, uh, reinterpreting it. They
hate the Quran. They wish Allah never
said what he said.